[Music]
dino here
in this video we're going to cover
apogee tracing
if you haven't got a working api proxy
with api key verification
stop here and go back and view the prior
videos now
in the apogee ui select the proxy we
created previously
this proxy has the verify api key policy
let's use that to learn about tracing
select the trace tab
clicking this green button tells apigee
to begin collecting diagnostic
information for each request it receives
for the proxy
let's invoke the api again and we'll see
how that works
i want to make sure i pass a valid api
key
in the trace window you can see
immediately i have a trace record
for that request
exploring here i can see the properties
of the inbound request
and also the results of the verify api
key policy
i can also see the outbound request
being sent to the target
and what's this the api key is being
passed to the back end
that's because the apogee edge proxy is
passing through the request
unchanged if we want to avoid that
we can configure the proxy to modify the
request
to remove that query parameter let's do
that
in the preflow i'll add and assign
message policy a sign message
is a multi-purpose policy that can be
used to set or change
any part of a message normally
apogee edge propagates an exact copy of
the inbound message to the target
but with a signed message you can make
changes adding or removing headers
adding or removing query parameters
i'm going to configure this policy to
remove the query parameter
save the proxy flip back to the trace
tab
start a trace session
now invoke the api and flip back to
trace
and we can see the assigned message
policy is removing the query parameter
the proxy is no longer leaking that api
key to the back end
great apigee edge trace gives near
real-time diagnostic information to api
proxy developers during development
it will show you up to 20 transactions
now it's not intended to deliver a log
of transactions for that you can use the
message logging policy
in this video we use the trace facility
and we tried the assigned message policy
that's just one of the set of 30 plus
policies that are built into apogee edge
don't forget to learn more check out the
product documentation
and visit the community site to explore
further
be sure to watch the next video in this
series where we'll cover the api
developer portal
till next time keep it digital